every man's life ends the same way
it is only the details of how he lived
and how he died
that distinguished one man from another
there are so many women with whom you
can sleep
and so few women with whom you can talk
courage is grace under pressure
they wrote in the old days that it is
sweet and fitting to die for one's
country
but in modern war there is nothing sweet
nor fitting in your dying
you will die like a dog for no good
reason
the world breaks every one end afterward
many are strong at the broken places
fear of death increases in exact
proportion to increase in wealth
the human being is the only animal that
can laugh
even though he has least occasions for
that
worry a little bit every day and in a
lifetime you will lose a couple of years
if something is wrong
fix it if you can
but train yourself not to worry
worry never fixes anything
there is no lonelier man in death
than that man who has lived many years
with a good wife and then outlived her
if two people love each other there can
be no happy end to it
i like to listen
i have learned a great deal from
listening carefully
most people never listen
i love to go to the zoo
but not on sunday
i don't like to see the people making
fun of the animals
when it should be the other way around
there is nothing noble than being
superior to your fellow man
true nobility is being superior to your
former self
life isn't hard to manage when you've
nothing to lose
now is no time to think of what you do
not have
think of what you can do with that there
is
the thing is to become a master in your
old age
to acquire the courage to do what
children did when they knew nothing
going to another country doesn't make
any difference
i've tried all that
you can't get away from yourself by
moving from one place to another
there's nothing to that
no
that is the great fallacy
the wisdom of old men
they do not grow wise
they grow careful
so far about morals
i only know that what is moral is what
you feel good after
and what is immoral is what you feel bad
after women made such swell friends
awfully swell
in the first place you had to be in love
with a woman to have a basis of
friendship
all thinking men are atheists
never think that war no matter how
necessary
nor how justified
is not a crime
there is no friend as loyal as a book
but man is not made for defeat
a man can be destroyed but not defeated
never confuse movement with action
a cat has absolute emotional honesty
human beings for one reason or another
may hide their feelings
but a cat does not
there's no one thing that's true
it's all true
never go on trips with anyone you do not
love
if you are lucky enough to have lived in
paris as a young man
then wherever you go for the rest of
your life
it stays with you
for paris is a movable feast
right hard and clear about what hurts
in order to write about life
first you must live it
when you love you wish to do things for
you wish to sacrifice for
you wish to serve
the first and final thing you have to do
in this world
is to last it
and not be smashed by it
all things truly wicked start from
innocence
the hard part about writing a novel
is finishing it
we are all broken
that's how the light gets in
when you start to live outside yourself
it's all dangerous
everyone behaves badly
given the chance
the real reason for not committing
suicide
is because you always know how swell
life gets again
after the hell is over
the best way to find out if you can
trust somebody
is to trust them
the world is a fine place and worth
fighting for and i hate very much to
leave it
you're unsettled about your appearance
because you're not sure of yourself
you shouldn't be ashamed of yourself
because it's your feature
exactly what makes you
you
the one who forgave the betrayal
is waiting for a new betrayal
there isn't always an explanation for
everything
if a man isn't looking for friends
then he is his own enemy
wine is a grand thing
it makes you forget all the bad
the most painful thing is losing
yourself in the process of loving
someone too much
and forgetting that you are special too
be afraid of a friend who often says
flattery to you
too flatter means to tell a person
exactly what he thinks about himself
if you don't have obvious enemies
then they are hiding among your friends
an intelligent man is something forced
to be drunk to spend time with his fools
work every day
no matter what has happened the day or
night before
get up and bite on the nail
there are many who do not know they are
fascists but we'll find it out when the
time comes
prose is architecture
not interior decoration
all cowardice comes from not truly
loving
or at least not loving well
every day
is a new day
it is better to be lucky
but i would rather be exact
then when luck comes
you are ready
[Music]
you